[Musique]
bonjour gérard larcher bonjour alors une
mamans voilées qui accompagnent une
sortie scolaire est ce que vous dites
comme jean michel blanquer
ce n'est pas souhaitable le port du
voile est ce que vous dites c'est une
exhibition religieuse de ce que vous
disent c'est pas si grave jeudi que
service public de l'éducation doit être
un lieu de neutralité et lors de
l'examen de la loi sur le vote sur
l'école de la confiance le sénat a voté
un amendement qui considère que les
sorties scolaires font partie du temps
scolaire sont d'ailleurs un élément de
l'éducation et que sur ce sujet il
faudra pas avoir un débat qui oppose les
uns aux autres tout simplement appliquer
la loi de 1905 c'est le dont nous avons
parlé avec marcel gaucher à quelques
mois et se dire que ces toiles 1900 sa
cadette une loi de liberté donc une
maman peut porter le voile mais quand tu
les auxiliaires de l'école elle doit
entrer dans les règles de l'école pour
une maman voilée comme pour une maman
d'une autre confession qu'il faut de
nouveaux légiférer c'est tout simple le
23 octobre puisque notre amendement du
sénat qui a été largement voté sera
représenté sous forme d'une proposition
de loi peut faire tout ça de manière
apaisée et sans doute en adaptant parce
que je suis pas insensible à la réalité
de mayotte ou de la réunion le problème
c'est que cette femme qui a témoigné ce
matin dit je me sent exclu qu'elle est
quelle est ma place de maman d'élève les
femmes qui portent le voile il ya une
partie d'ailleurs de la majorité qui
explique que la voit plutôt les faire
les intégrer l'école mais bien sûr qu
acteur mais j'ai l'impression de
réentendre j'étais tout jeune
parlementaire le débat de creil crois
que des règles nous sommes un état
laïque
nous avons une neutralité du service
public et encore plus dans l'éducation
donc faisons tout ça de manière apaisée
savez cette société est fracturée
parfois aussi le port de signes
religieux est une manière de se séparer
de la communauté nationale
je rêve d'une communauté nationale au
singulier
or nous vivons le communautarisme voilà
pourquoi il est important que le
président de la république puisse
s'exprimer notamment sur la loi de 1905
voilà pourquoi nous l'avons fait avec
marcel gaucher parce que c'est pour nous
un principe qui parmi les principes
fondateurs de la convoyer une femme
voilée je n'ai aucun problème dans
l'espace public
vous y voyez moi que je ces missions
vous y voyez à une religion à une
domination masculine
vous y voyez un acte politique c'est ce
qu'elle dise ce qu'il considère qu'apple
dévoile ce que nielsen je vous assure
que le port du voile est une marque
d'engagement politique de licence aux
politiciens une part d'une forme d'islam
politique et d'islam radical chez un
certain nombre de ceux qui portent le
voile chez d'autres la ricine
d'appartenances religieuses
l'appartenance à une communauté
religieuse qui ne faut jamais que c'est
que sa coupe de la communauté nationale
c'est donc pas de problème sauf que
j'insiste le service public de l'année
de l'éducation tallieu de neutralité
politique et religieuse
je crois vous avez dit ça fait 30 ans
vous étiez jeune parlementaire on était
déjà en train de débattre parce que même
chose parce que le sujet en fait n'a pas
vraiment été tranchée par le politique
voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il faut
revenir aux fondamentaux de la loi de
1905 et que nous attendons sur ce sujet
parole du président de la république qui
l'a reportée moult fois il a un moment
même pensé faire évoluer loi 1905
parce que c'est un sujet sans doute
difficile mais c'est un sujet essentiel
où on attend un président de la
république qui rassemble qui fasse que
nos compatriotes de religion d'origine
musulmane se sentent autant partie de la
république que les aides que les athées
les catholiques où les juifs mais vous
voyez bien que c'est compliqué vous le
savez je ne vais pas compliqué 90
personnalités ont signé une tribune pour
dire stop à la haine contre les
musulmans est ce que qu'est ce que vous
leur dites à cela mais que je suis
la haine vis-à-vis des musulmans
naturellement ça n'a aucun sens line
vis-à-vis des musulmans
c'est même contraire aux valeurs de la
république et en tous les cas moi jamais
vous m'entendrez dans la haine je suis
toujours dans le rassemblement et sur
ces sujets là pour garder les problèmes
en face nous avons un sujet de
neutralité à l'école publique il faut le
traiter sans haine sans faiblesse un
sujet très concret le président dit il
faut lutter contre l'hydre islamiste
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré lors de
l'hommage aux victimes de la tuerie de
la préfecture il ya une circulaire des
personnels de l'université de cergy
pontoise qui a énormément choqué leur
demandant de détecter des signaux
faibles de radicalisation
comment est-ce qu'on tranche ce sujet là
sans tomber dans la stigmatisation
simplement avoué être des citoyens en
éveil est des citoyens attentifs être
des citoyens attentifs à tout ce qui
s'écarte des valeurs communes de la
république att sa religion c'est
s'écarter de la république non pratiquer
sa religion d'une manière apaisée et au
contraire dans la république la loi de
1905 est une loi de liberté liberté
d'exercer le culte de son choix
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
liberté donnée aux aux églises et aux
organisations religieuses de l'exercer
mais il n'ya qu'une loi il faut bien
avoir ça en tête
c'est la loi de la république aucune loi
n'est supérieure à la loi de la
république
on peut avoir sa loi personnelle mais on
doit respecter la loi de la république
une image qui vous a peut-être choquer
je voudrais en parler avec vous ce matin
celle des pompiers qui se sont affrontés
hier pompiers qui manifestèrent pour la
reconnaissance de deux des conditions
difficiles d'exercice de leurs de leur
métier qui se sont affrontés avec des
policiers est ce que c'est révélateur
d'un climat qui vous inquiète
c'était au tour de climat en même temps
policiers pompiers selon la plupart du
temps ensemble au service de la
population et quelque part ça me blesse
parce que j'ai été élu local
nous allons nous retrouver à bourges au
congrès des départements c'est une
responsabilité départementale majeur
mais il faut que l'exécutif entendre ce
que disent les présidents de conseils
département
la situation faite aux sapeurs pompiers
qu'on appelle pour tous dans des
conditions de plus en plus dangereuse
dans des conditions parfois de non
reconnaissance de leur métier ça appelle
ça appelle à une réponse à une réponse
globale nationale mais en mettant
faisons confiance
non ça me renvoie mon approche à la
décentralisation et au départ tout alors
vous terminez je lisais votre tour de
france des territoires veut publier un
livre s'appelle contre-pouvoir vous
aviez dans ce livre commencé à laisser
planer le doute enfin c'est comme ça que
certains l'ont compris sur vos ambitions
pour 2022 je n'exclus rien je sais pas
exactement quelle est la formule mais ça
ressemblait un peu à ça avant de vous
raser de vous raviser je ne suis pas du
tout rire jusqu'à le rôle voulez vous
jouer si j'ai une ambition peut-être si
mais confie mes collègues font confiance
et de être élu président du sénat en
2020 pour achever la tâche mais le titre
contre-pouvoir fait quoi le sénat est
devenu vraiment un contre-pouvoir non
pas l anti pouvoir
un contre-pouvoir parce que depuis
l'évolution du quinquennat dans
l'évolution politique qui est la nôtre
la seule assemblée on l'a vu pas
simplement sur le dossier pénal a mais
sur le dossier par exemple de la
taxation des carburants sur la
privatisation des aéroports de paris sur
le dossier vu de manière apaisée de la
laïcité que le contre-pouvoir c'était le
céda et senna tout entier pas simplement
gérard larcher un nouveau patron à la
tête de l air christian jacob ça change
quoi qu'est ce que vous en espérez
certains ont quitté le navire jean
pierre raffarin qui tlr d'ailleurs oui
je croyais que c'était déjà fait mais
moi je suis et l'air je vais aider au
redressement de la formation politique à
la reconstruction de son projet c'est
aussi le fruit de mon tour de france
mais au rassemblement des familles du
centre et de la droite
il faut qu'on offre une alternative on
peut pas rester dans le système binaire
soit le rassemblement national soit la
république en marche ça c'est pas
possible pour la démocratie
je me battrai pour ça j'ai pas envie de
la même image en 2022
au soir du deuxième tour les deux même
visage qu'en 2017
merci